the mad scramble over president biden's
nearly two trillion dollar coronavirus
relief
package right now democrats are leading
the effort to push the measure in the
evenly divided senate they hope to allow
another round of government resources to
be in place when the latest round
of federal unemployment benefits is set
to expire late next week
the measure calls for fourteen hundred
dollar stimulus checks to americans
making seventy five thousand dollars a
year
or less emergency grants and loans to
small businesses
state and local government aid money for
public health
and an extension of unemployment
benefits on friday the labor department
reported 379
000 new jobs were added to the nation's
economy last month
mr biden says that proves the urgency of
this relief package
we are covering the store from capital
story from capitol hill and the white
house
this morning where it has been a long
night we'll begin with chris van cleave
on capitol hill
uh chris i hope you're not too tired
what's the latest there right now
well good morning jeff we are about 20
hours
20 amendments three of which passed and
one motion to adjourn
into this and still going senate
majority leader chuck schumer said
late last night make no mistake we're
going to continue working
until we get the job done well that job
is not done
yet the senate's voterama got
sidetracked for 12
hours by what some were calling voter
drama
democrats spent half a day deadlocked
over an amendment dealing with
unemployment benefits
after sometimes heated discussions hold
out joe manchin of west virginia
agreed to extend federal unemployment
benefits through early september
but lower the amount from 400 to 300
weekly that matches the current figure
the amendment will also make some
unemployment benefits tax-free
once that deal was in place the actual
vote-a-rama could get started
this is part of an arcane legislative
process known as reconciliation where
the senate can pass this 1.9 trillion
dollar covert relief bill with a simple
majority
but first every single senator gets to
offer as many amendments as they want
and republicans
have a lot of amendments why because it
lets them force
democrats to vote on issues they might
not otherwise want to
something you can bring up later in say
an attack at now one of the big
questions this congress has been how
long could senate majority leader chuck
schumer keep his
razor thin majority in lock step
well yesterday that lasted until about
noon
it underscores just how precarious
a 50-50 split in the senate can be one
thing that is working in the democrats
favor here
is republicans are down a senator dan
sullivan of alaska is attending a family
funeral so right now there is a 59-49
majority here in the senate for
democrats
we expect a vote possibly later today
likely to pass on a party line vote dana
all right chris thank you precarious the
key word there obviously